what is a premise and why is it
important in writing I think the premise
is the idea you're trying to tell in
that point of view that you have because
ideas are can be repeated so many times
right but it's your take on that
material so again we were talking about
Juno earlier right and that story has
been told so many times that girl who
gets pregnant but the premise of that
was beyond that you know it was this
teenage girl that gets pregnant and has
all of this family and she doesn't want
to have an abortion she wants to give
the baby app for adoption right so that
is their take and their point of view
they have a vision so the premise of
your story is really what sets the basis
but then it's about how you develop that
into a fleshed out story so a lot of
times when I'm you know Consulting on
scripts I can tell them your premise is
good your story kind of falters so you
have a good setup of an idea what you
have here has legs or there's a seat of
an idea your premise is there it's just
the way you approached it is not working
because of different things it can be
the structure or the protagonist is not
fleshed out enough so we're not seeing
an evolution or things like that you
know but that premise is the first step
that needs to be there it's your point
of view on how you're telling the story
you're telling why is it hard to find a
new take in this day and age I mean is
it true that everything's already been
written I don't think that absolutely
everything has been written but yes so
much has been written before but if you
can find a new take on old material I
think that that makes it fresh you know
we've seen a lot of those things lately
uh for example Maleficent you know
that's a new take we hadn't seen that
story from the point of view of the
villain obviously you couldn't just go
write that if you don't own the rights
but that's a good example to see on how
a new take on something that's been told
so many times before can make the
material feel completely fresh so this
is common especially with television I
would say let's say medical shows or
lawyer shows police shows you know all
of the
procedurals there's so many that come
out every single year right and
audiences like them so they work we all
like to watch the different medical
shows the different lawyer shows the
different police shows but it's the new
take that it's going to make them unique
if you just write another medical show
without a fresh take then he won't make
it past the desk of anyone because those
are a d dozen you know like there's so
many out there but for example if you go
with a good doc the good doctor right
that's a fresh take on a surgical show
because the protagonist has autism you
know that makes that show unique because
the protagonist is different as someone
we had not seen before uh for example if
you're talking about lawyer shows uh
suits was a great new show because it
was about a lawyer who wasn't actually a
lawyer he lied his way and because he
had a photographic memory so he pretends
to be a lawyer where he actually never
attended law school you know The Good
Wife is another ex example because it's
about a housewife who was a lawyer 15
years ago left to be a mom basically and
then had to go back after her husband
had an affair and she had to support her
family those are new takes on material
we've seen a million times before like
these shows that come out every year but
that makes them fresh so if you can find
the new take then you weigh of telling a
story uh in cup shows for example
Homeland did that you know we had never
seen a protagonist that off a show like
that that was in the CIA or FBI or
something like that that had bipolar
disorder order that was fresh that made
that show unique or for example Sons of
Anarchy the world of that story is what
made it so unique we had never seen a
show about bikers on TV that's a fresh
take on a family story because that's a
show all about family but the background
made it feel fresh because we hadn't
seen that on television that made it
appealing so if you can find that you
can make your story unique because yes
it's hard to find new stories and I know
how much writers struggle with that
every day because so much is out there
and that's why again you can't copyright
just an idea because there's they're all
out there it's just the way you tell it
your take on the material is what's
going to make it fresh and what's going
to make it unique and your voice and how
you tell it how does a writer know they
have a bad
premise I don't think writers realize it
so they probably need the notes and
that's where a script consultant would
come in you know just letting you know
you know your premise is just not strong
enough maybe you need to find a new take
or you need a new angle on the story
that's where I always say notes are
important and it can't just be you know
your best friend that doesn't know about
story uh it's good you know to start
with the basics sometimes you swap
scripts with other writers you know
things like that you start getting ideas
and stories from uh you know like notes
on your stories and things like that but
if you really want to assess your script
I think that Consulting with someone who
can really give you
a real assessment of like the
marketability or how your take would be
seen by producers someone like that
that's where you should reach out to
someone you know with more experience in
that sense that can tell you you know
your story is not really working because
your premise is not strong enough you
don't have enough to tell this story
because it's too bland or there's not
enough conflict or it's just been told
too many times and you haven't found a
fresh take on it this is going to be a
little strange but should someone
consult more than one person because
what if someone's for lack of a better
term a poisonous penmate and they kind
of want to smash the person whether it's
a friend whether it's a person in a
class I mean this reality that exists if
someone's told by someone that their
story isn't really strong and there's a
million reasons why how much should they
believe it and how much should they
think I'm being sabotaged what if
they're not and it's really just not a
good story when do they know I think
that you should definitely consult more
than one person and I
myself as the consultant have told
clients you know we've consulted enough
on the script I think that you should
reach out to someone else and I give
them ideas of who they could talk to so
they can keep working on it uh or
sometimes you know you don't connect
with the material but you know that they
could be someone that can make that
script better and you see it happen all
the time especially with TV shows you
hear the stories about writers you know
Mad Men was written like I think 10
years before he actually made it to the
air and he kept getting rejected and
things like that you know so yes I
obviously I always say I'm a consultant
this is my opinion on your story but I'm
not the one and only person that can
tell you this works or this doesn't work
or your story has no value I feel like
you should consult with others the same
way you know you get notes from
different people and the notes defer we
were talking earlier about how I like to
get the notes that are people are have
given my clients and kind of like with
them together in a more cohesive way
because sometimes the notes are very
different there are Services out there
with that offer coverage that offer you
more than one reader and I think those
are great because you get different
perspectives on the script and you can
see the note behind the note as I call
it so sometimes people can tell you you
know this is not working for me or this
is not working for me but it doesn't
necessarily have to be that you have to
follow their suggestion is just you
should look behind that note and see why
that area is not working for people you
know you could find a different approach
and how to fix that issue you don't have
to necessarily follow that's why I
always say I'm giving suggestions I'm
not telling you do this with your script
or do this thing you know I'm just kind
of Illuminating the different areas that
are not fully
working and giving you ideas on what
could make them work sometimes the
writer finds them better way of making
them work than I had even imagined you
know but it's just about pointing out
those different things so I think that
approaching more than one consultant is
always good because it's going to
elevate your writing even
more